(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Monkeys definitely
feed off of your feelings.
They know when you're feeling down,
or when you're feeling funny.
It's kind of an urban legend
that people out there are training monkeys
to help people with disabilities,
but that really happens.
- Nice going, too.
I have my monkey, Casey,
for 10 years.
In 2005, I was in a car accident.
I injured C1, C2, the spinal cord,
with a brain injury.
I couldn't move
really anything at all.
I couldn't talk.
You know, I've come a long way.
- Our goal is to train
and place capuchin monkeys
with people living with
mobility impairments.
The program got its start
really as an experiment,
to say, we can train a dog
to help somebody who
has visual impairment,
perhaps we can train a
primate to be the hands
for somebody who has had
a spinal cord injury.
We provide our monkeys at
no charge to our recipients.
- Good fetch!
- [Megan] All of our monkeys
are born into our program.
Typically a monkey will spend
about three to five years
at the monkey college,
learning tasks, whether
that's fetching a phone
or a remote control off the floor.
- Atta girl, Daisy, atta girl.
- [Megan] Helping somebody
get something to drink.
- Good job, girl.
- Even something
as complicated as flipping
the pages of a book.
The monkeys do really act as hands
and give them that level
of independence back.
You can imagine having
a spinal cord injury
and all of a sudden you have a monkey
that's sitting on your shoulder
and you can finally feel that touch.
To have that monkey there
is an incredible bonding experience.
- When I couldn't move
Casey did a lot for me.
Casey, brush.
Now it's a lot of emotional support.
It's a lot of companionship.
Casey is part of my family.
You know, this is a five-pound animal
that is extraordinarily helpful
and brings joy to my life.
(upbeat music)
(electronic music)